you talk about um your friendship with
tom
right and i can only assume this is tom
shady actually it is right of course it
is it's like
this is definitely tom and he has this
great line
where he tells you uh your generation
has an idolatry
of magnitude and and it's probably one
of my favorite lines in the whole book
so
let's spend a few minutes talking about
what that means
well he i remember he originally said
that
talking about invisible children and he
was
because we were at invisible children
not only were we trying to arrest joseph
kony and
end the longest running war in central
east africa but we also wanted to change
the world
we wanted to bolster international human
rights we wanted
war crimes against children to be
something that everyone on the planet
cares about and rallies around
it was such this like giant
thing and pinning it all on
arresting joseph coney and seeing him
tried before the icc was such
this like if we haven't done that we
have failed and he would always say he's
such a
mentor in our life he's like you have
put thousands of kids through schools
you have
built schools you have awakened hundreds
of thousands if not millions of western
teenagers
to international human rights to caring
about something outside their building
and their small world you have gotten
bills passed
through the obama administration to help
with the pursuit of these war criminals
you've done an you've done so much and
you can't see it
because you've decided if you do not
turn the world upside down and change it
then you have failed
and that robs you of
both the stamina provided by incremental
success
and also just the reality of
understanding that it's not everyone's
duty to change the world
changing someone's life right in front
of you
or one child's life or five children's
lives whatever is
so cosmically significant and if you
overlook that then you damage and
disrespect the impact you've already had
or are having and i think a lot of
people whether it's
i talk with my agent and my editor about
this a lot because i get asked by people
how do i get published
how do i get notice how do i get an
agent and
the the question is
that my agent calls it the hidden desire
behind the question
it's like what what is the spirit of
your question
because is it actually how do i get
validated
for my writing and and i need validation
he says
it's also the hidden desire in the
question when someone says how do you
handle the critics
and that the hidden
nature of that question is how do i
i really care what people think about my
products
so much so that i'm i'm so afraid of
putting it out there because what if
someone doesn't like it and i need
validation
for my work and so there's just this
like idea that if i'm not
published and on a bookshelf if i'm not
this or that if i haven't achieved a b c
d or any then i'm not a real blank
right and i think in the journey of
figuring out what you're good at and
what love what you love and what loves
you and what you're supposed to be doing
and how you can be
useful and helpful in this life is
is if you feel a pull towards something
no matter how big or small
then like in some way try it and that
was my entire intention with
writing to shake the sleeping self was i
don't know if i can write a book i
actually
might be bad and i might embarrass
myself but
i'm willing to try and put it out there
and i'm so happy to self-publish because
i just want to hold it in my hands and
know i did a thing
and then i can move on with my life and
find some other job or
if the wind doesn't tack in that
direction i'll attack the other way
great
i can do that but the writing was a
compulsion it was something that had to
be birthed you had to express
it there was a call to the doing of it
it wasn't about can i get an agent or a
book deal
it was about basically the process of
of of giving voice to this thing that
was inside of you
totally the writing in and of itself is
the thing i wanted to do because
i had learned that
when i would write something originally
i had a blog
on blogspot which then became tumblr and
it was called the water is black
which i love that title which came from
a poem about being gay and god hating me
and so i
would write my thoughts about my like
sexuality and christianity on this blog
just so because they when something
would really bother me
this happens to me now like something
will really
eat up my mind but i can't i can feel
the war of ideas in my head
and then it's like i just need to go sit
down and write about this and do some
research and figure out what i think
right so it's the writing that gives you
clarity on
you know what you actually believe about
a specific thing
well i don't know if you go for a number
of days without working out
your my body starts to like ache
hurt it's like i don't know if that's
atrophy or just stiffness but it's like
if i don't exercise then my body bothers
me
and so then i go sweat and i get the
endorphins and i feel limber and great
in the same way if i don't like if i'm
absorbing the world
and something's happening something
complex like
like right now i'm fascinated by the
concept of multiculturalism
and assimilation into a nation right now
with the
the whole conversation around france and
what they're doing with so many
muslim immigrants and how
unlike america which is famed for being
a melting pot
france is like a really old country with
like a very established
multi-thousand-year-old
traditional indigenous identity
and so them processing that is
so short-circuiting to my mind because i
i see both sides of the argument and i
mean it's obviously short-circuiting
lots of people's minds
but it like so for example i i'm gonna
eventually have to write this out even
if it's just for me
because it's really it's something i
can't
get a hold of and it's like bothering me
so originally i would do that with my
sexuality and my faith
and i would do it on this blog and
one time and i don't know why but i just
felt
really fired up and i posted it on my
facebook
just like i don't know why i felt ready
to do that and i did
and it and it was that where people
a lot of my friends read it and then
they sent it to their friends and their
friends of friends and strangers were
messaging me saying this was so helpful
and that that was like some moment in my
life
right where that felt really where i did
something that was good for me
and i discovered it was useful for
someone else and that like
really pulled me forward in loving that
yeah it's it's amazing how powerful a
small
seemingly small thing like that can be
in giving you the courage the gumption
to push forward on something and kind of
uh you know broaden the spectrum
of what's possible for yourself because
in the moment
it's just it's not a big deal like a
couple other people read your thing and
thought it was cool
but how meaningful that was and even now
you look
oh you know new york times best selling
bestseller but
it's i'm sure for you it's the
handwritten letters that you get
in the mail from some kid in the south
who feels alone
[Music]
you